♪♪
Narrator:
TO MAKE ICE-CREAM TREATS,
YOU FIRST HAVE TO MAKE
THE ICE CREAM.
IT ALL BEGINS WITH FRESH CREAM.
THE FACTORY STORES IT
IN REFRIGERATED SILOS
SET JUST A FEW DEGREES
ABOVE FREEZING.
THE SILOS FEED
A HIGH-SPEED MIXER
THAT BLENDS THE CREAM
WITH OTHER INGREDIENTS.
THE MAIN DRY INGREDIENTS
ARE POWDERED SKIM MILK
AND PLANT-BASED STABILIZERS
AND EMULSIFIERS.
STABILIZERS PREVENT THE ICE
CREAM FROM CRYSTALLIZING,
AND EMULSIFIERS ALLOW THE MIX
TO BOND WITH AIR
DURING THE WHIPPING PROCESS.
THE OTHER INGREDIENTS ARE SUGAR
AND CORN SYRUP.
AFTER ABOUT THREE MINUTES
OF MIXING,
A PUMPING SYSTEM MOVES
THE MIXTURE
INTO PASTEURIZATION TANKS
AND HEATS IT TO 162 DEGREES
FOR HALF AN HOUR,
KILLING ANY BACTERIA
AND ACTIVATING THE STABILIZERS.
THEN THE FACTORY HOMOGENIZES
THE MIXTURE,
A PROCESS THAT BREAKS UP
THE FAT GLOBULES,
GIVING THE ICE CREAM
A SMOOTH TEXTURE.
THE MIXTURE IS COOLED,
AND CONCENTRATED VANILLA
FLAVORING IS ADDED.
THEN THE CONCOCTION
IS CHILLED AND WHIPPED
FOR ABOUT 15 SECONDS.
WHIPPING BLENDS THE MIX
WITH AIR,
TRANSFORMING IT
FROM A LIQUID TO A SOFT SOLID.
WITHOUT AIR,
THE FINISHED PRODUCT
WOULD COME OUT LOOKING
LIKE FROZEN MILK
RATHER THAN ICE CREAM IF IT
WASN'T WHIPPED.
THE ICE-CREAM-SANDWICH WAFERS
ARE MADE
OF CHOCOLATE-CAKE INGREDIENTS.
A FILLING MACHINE FEEDS
TWO LINES OF WAFERS
TOWARD AN INJECTION PIPE.
JUST AS TWO WAFERS
COME TOGETHER,
THE MACHINE INJECTS
A THIRD OF A CUP
OF VANILLA ICE CREAM
IN BETWEEN.
THE PIPE'S HEAD SHAPES
THE ICE CREAM
INTO A RECTANGULAR SLAB
THAT FITS PERFECTLY
BETWEEN THE WAFERS.
ALL THIS HAPPENS AT A RATE
OF 140 ICE-CREAM SANDWICHES
PER MINUTE.
AS THE SANDWICHES MOVE ON
TO PACKAGING,
THE FILLING IS STILL ICE-COLD
FROM THE FREEZING PHASE,
SO THERE IS NO THREAT
OF A MELTDOWN.
THE PACKAGING SYSTEM RAISES
EACH SANDWICH INTO A WRAPPER,
THEN FOLDS AND TUCKS THE ENDS.
THE NEXT MACHINE
COUNTS THE SANDWICHES
AND INSERTS THEM INTO BOXES.
ONCE SEALED, THE BOXES GO
DIRECTLY INTO A STORAGE FREEZER
AT MINUS-22 DEGREES.
ON ANOTHER LINE,
ICE-CREAM-CONE PRODUCTION
IS UNDER WAY.
A FEEDER DROPS
PREWRAPPED SUGAR CONES
INTO HOLDERS ON A CONVEYOR BELT.
SPRAYERS COAT THE INSIDES
WITH A CHOCOLATY LAYER,
WHICH ADDS FLAVOR
AND CREATES A BARRIER
BETWEEN THE CONES AND ICE CREAM
SO THE CONE REMAINS CRISPY
UNTIL YOU EAT IT.
NEXT, NOZZLES SQUIRT
IN THE ICE-CREAM FILLING.
ONE PRODUCTION LINE,
TWO FLAVORS.
ONE ROW
GETS VANILLA ICE CREAM,
THE OTHER CHOCOLATE.
NOW FOR A TASTY SURPRISE
IN THE CONE'S CORE --
AN INJECTION OF LIQUID CARAMEL.
THIS FACTORY ALSO MAKES
CHOCOLATE AND STRAWBERRY SAUCE
INSIDE.
NEXT, A CHOCOLATE-FLAVORED
LIQUID TOPPING.
THEN THE CRUNCHY
FINISHING TOUCH --
A LAYER OF CHOCOLATY-COATED
PUFFED RICE.
FINALLY, THE CONES MOVE
UNDER A LID DISPENSER
THAT APPLIES A WAX-COATED,
PAPER LID TO EACH ONE.
A HEATING ELEMENT
INSTANTLY MELTS THE WAX,
SEALING THE LIDS
TO THE CONE'S PAPER SLEEVE.
FROM HERE, THE ICE-CREAM CONES
GO INTO BOXES,
THEN STRAIGHT INTO THE FREEZER,
READY TO TAKE A LICKING.